it's time for roses and Rosie hi you
guys
so tonight we're taking things behind
the scenes because I was behind the
scenes of this weekend's hilt in the
head date with Rachel and her boys by
behind the scenes I mean you're going to
you're going to see me open this okay
I'm sure and this is a twist off top
everybody keeping it Wow
okay really there we go now I'm an
independent woman for the record but
this was very I think the heat had
sealed it shut okay more importantly Wow
I'm the epitome of elegance and so is
Rachel per usual on Monday night's
episode of The Bachelorette let's talk
about it I'm wearing some statement
earrings and Lee made a lot of
unsettling statements number one way you
can piss somebody off is you just laugh
at him make a fool of him okay drink
every time he makes one yikes
I just wrote at the top of my notes
drama drama drama I come here to come
here the man drama really came to a head
this week firstly was like hovering
around somebody else's date and that was
super weird
and then he gave Rachel some wood a
block of wood and I think he'd written
enchanting on it and he said something
about how he wanted to pull her
heartstrings so drink to that that was
weird
I'm here to pull Rachel's heartstrings
I'm thinking I might have a grip now
every scene was like I'm southern and so
charming and now it's like I'm southern
and so disarming okay Oh
so we've being weird and Dean puts out a
pretty serious implication on why he's
being weird
from a cultural perspective what do you
mean you know exactly what I mean
it's not cool a lot of the guys are
being weird though Rachel is also scared
of Brian and then brian says in the
fairy tale fairy tale Wow and she was
like do it nice a reality show what
happens when it's like real life good
Rob Rachel keep your head in the game so
the matter too dramatic and Rachel's is
set over at nettle flamer
and then Chris Harrison comes in and
says you just have to tell me what you
want I can facilitate anything so some
people are set at home including diggie
and his cool glasses
this was sad I don't know anything about
diggie except for those cool glasses Oh
calm down okay so now we're in a blimp
and you know people say this show isn't
a people say this show isn't
intellectual talk about educating the
people have you ever seen the inside of
a blimp I am NOT you have to buckle up
in those things I did not know that did
you know that also I kind of forgot
blimps existed one last time you thought
about a blimp Dean guys this was the
episode of being lean not so mean super
sweet Dean they had any more things that
Ryan would seem
not really okay so being share this
story about his mother passing away and
what his family went through it was such
a great story and I love when the show
has real moments and shares people's
real pain in a way that makes other
people feel connected so that we all are
not alone I don't know like did you
notice how when I said that my eyes kept
following my wine I was like don't leave
me alone okay now we go to a hill Ned
Island I don't know what the accent is
down there but I'm doing that
welcome to the bachelor nation Spelling
Bee
guys I was there in Hilton Head I was in
the set of this date and let me tell you
we only saw some of the words felled
there were way more and we'll and
Anthony and Josiah killed it
Josiah won it we saw him win it and then
he made out with that trophy like it was
Rachel how do you like me now hahahaha
weird there's a behind the scenes look
at the date over ABC online.com okay I'm
unclear on why it was a spelling bee
Dayton Hilton met I asked on the set and
no one had a real answer for me I don't
know why we went to Hill to have a
spelling team I don't think any type of
National Spelling Bee is held there but
the spelling of facade by Eric hmm that
was
that was a tra vsp why Anthony's pace
said it all so then I forget how but
somehow Rachel ended up talking to Peter
and I still love Peter and did everyone
hear this little bomb reto dropped I'm
licensed to practice the Wisconsin
are you really she can practice law in
Wisconsin okay okay as a reminder Rachel
lives in Texas you don't just say things
like oh I will absolutely move if you're
not into the guy
so Peter still a front-runner for me
well I like Dean lob this week and she
still seems really into charmer Brian
fairy tale because I'm so positive and
so genuine it comes off as disingenuous
all right now at this point by the time
we're here Lee is scaring the actual out
of me
Lea is saying grab that is so villainous
and vile and manipulative ma ni pul a TI
ve and weird
wer i D so again drink every time he
says something really unsettling no he
screamed at me I don't give a about
Kimmy
it's a 220-pound ballerina
[Music]
okay that would be my talent in the
talent show and I'm sure there will be a
talent show date at some point huh it's
a lot of like the dates are a lot of
like childhood tropes how did about to
help you find your spouse it's weird
what the hell is happening now
[Music]
we get a big tease next week ramaa next
week the big fight next week they always
keep us wanting more next week is a
two-part event one to Monday and Tuesday
night I'll be in here I'm looking for
commitment this girl she thought and did
French Peter freestyled and Rachel said
that it was really awesome
on tonight's date you guys
Peter freestyle and Rachel says that it
really really impressed her so I'm going
to try to freestyle for you here and now
rachel loves peter and he has a chance
to meet her by auditioning for the
Bachelorette it was the second time
around but you might have found the
clown who's going to be the laughter he
wants to get peter's real sexy he's got
a cap to the Rachel's real sexy she's
got one too I could see him making
babies that would be real cute Peter and
Rachel celeb renames facial or reader I
don't know how good that was but the
bottom line is I'm the female Eminem
I'll be honest overall it felt like a
filler episode still enjoy to fill still
loved it make sure to like ET on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube
follow me on instagram and snapchat and
Twitter we can talk about the
Bachelorette and how crazy we think we
might be guys thanks so much for
watching have a great night right
[Music]
so there's just the one time I lost my
phone home really awesome and really
while my hair looks like garbage
Wow I still it's the thing I'm not to do
with it okay